I've realized more and more that my
design aesthetic is real life don't
house I'm just trying to make myself
feel tiny
hello guys my name is grace Helbig ow ow
ow ow lead poisoning aah I don't think
about it it never happened
a few months ago I went to a shoe box
event at the improv here in Los Angeles
shoe box is the humor branch of hallmark
and they were relaunching themselves and
after the event they sent me a bunch of
their cards which was actually a very
sentimental experience for me because I
only have ever told any of you this but
when I moved to New York City after I
graduated college to pursue comedy the
first paid comedy gig I ever got was
writing greeting cards I say that very
loosely
somehow I got linked to a greeting
company in which you could email them
your greeting card ideas and you could
submit as many as you wanted and they
would pay you I think $100 per idea and
a few weeks after submitting ideas I
received a check for $200 they had taken
two of my ideas I never saw them made
into cards but I got paid for writing
comedy and it honestly at that moment
this was 2008 I thought well I have
arrived
look out entertainment world do you like
that two line greeting card hire me for
everything else but I submitted so many
ideas so they might have been paying me
just to stop it's the middle of
September and my birthday is at the end
of this month which reminded me that
other people have birthday so I'm gonna
send out some youtuber birthday cards I
have no idea when any of these youtubers
birthdays are I could easily google them
and they can also easily not google them
how can you not like if someone sends
you a birthday card and it's not your
birthday that's not a hate crime it's
not a crime it's confusing but in a cool
way like pudding what's that about what
am i got and who can we send them to oh
this one is a cat
and it says Oh God the Sun is so loud
right now make it shut up happy hangover
birthday Nikki limo
you just got birthday dear Nikki limo
ASL law JK but seriously look how
hilarious as cat is hating his son
hopefully because it's made a conscious
choice to avoid the Sun on account of
its introverted Ness not because it's
been kidnapped and kept in a closet for
years
anyway this card made me think of you
have a great birthday from grace PS
where did this cat thinks in English
sentences pretty presumptuous of us as a
culture oh this one says wine-tasting
etiquette correct incorrect
happy birthday Hannah March also does
that not look like Hannah Hart aunt dear
Hannah Hart the woman on the front of
this car it looks like a Craigslist
impersonator of Martha Stewart going to
a 2 Chainz party made me think of you
congratulations on another year closer
to death from grace what else do we have
Oh granny no panties is more like it
well happy birthday Michael Buckley have
a wild and free birthday dear Michael
Buckley I hope you're having a wild bye
to get six free birthday I'm sure
wherever you are right now you've
managed to somehow steal one of those
rhythmic gymnastic ribbons and are
twirling it in the face of people that
don't really want it in their face happy
birthday from grace me just like Michael
Bach they cannot be contained oh I got
one word for you three syllables may ma
write your memory this card made me
think of you no follow-up questions
happy birthday from grace if this
doesn't scream jenna Marbles I don't
know what does wait I do me jenna
Marbles dear Jenna Marbles sup not much
here everything that sheep are just
planning some long-winded slow rolling
take over the human race me neither its
artificial intelligence that will be our
downfall I agree anyway happy birthday
from grace may your day be more
beautiful than a unicorn farting
rainbows sing it with me
Lilly Singh that's from Shakespeare I
think happy birthday dear
leasing everything unicorns are just
horses with eyebrow rings remember
Claire's have a great birthday Congrats
on being alive from grace all I said was
let's have cake or let's eat kick or
something like that and suddenly
everyone got all pissy don't party with
peasants they ruin everything
truer words have never been spoken out
of the mouths of Tyler Oakley happy
birthday Tyler Tyler that's a beautiful
selfie dear Tyler Oakley hey Queen
literally Queen just got a new
definition and the new definition is its
actual definition sly you get a happy
birthday from grace follow me on Twitter
happy birthday dear Ingrid Nilsen have
you ever seen the movie x-men just look
at the front of this card now you have
happy birthday from grace a rare photo
of your parents the night you were
conceived dear future child of prank vs.
prank yes you were conceived during the
filming of the yoga challenge please
subscribe to my channel happy birthday
from grace stop I'm sorry
oh no my headshots got in there and
we're done
my youtuber birthday cards how do I get
these into their dm's
I don't know
thank you for the cards shoebox and for
bringing up something really fun
memories 2010 was a great year you guys
I look so good just a organic zest for
life where is it gone